assalamualaikum brothers and sisters now
I really didn't plan on making this
video but I had some of you reach out to
me and express your concerns over the
famous soccer player football player Mo
Salat brothers and sisters we've all had
loved ones that passed away a mother a
father a brother sister a close family
member for one of the mercies of our
Dean Islam is that we can have an
intention to do good deeds on our loved
ones behalf and what greater of a
continuous Good Deeds than investing on
their behalf in the Deeds Center a
Masjid and megadawa Center that will
benefit generations to come inshallah so
click the link below donate right now
may God Almighty Allah reward all of you
[Music]
again
celebrating the Mary Shirk and asks why
we weren't talking about this because
last year we ended up talking about uh
certain famous UFC fighter by the name
of hamzat who was playing the role of
Santa Claus but alhamdulillah I believe
that Hamza he got the message and
alhamdulillah he's not playing Santa
Claus this year alhamdulillah but
unfortunately our brother Mo Salat is
continuing on this tradition of Mary
shirk very unfortunate very sad now I
don't want to make this primarily about
him or the origins of this pagan holiday
and how it absolutely has nothing
whatsoever to do with Jesus peace be
upon him who we love who is so dear to
our hearts or how in the day of
information many many Christians are
getting educated on this and also
warning other Christians about this
pagan holiday but just for some
clarification I want to let you hear
what one of the leading voices in the
Christian world has to say about this
holiday who says we have friends who do
not celebrate Christmas because they say
to December 25th is really a pagan
holiday while I agree that Jesus may not
have been born on December 25th he
certainly was born as described in the
Bible how do I respond to them
well in a sense tell them the right you
see the the the winter solstice a couple
days later was the shortest day of the
year and the pagans had something called
saturnalia
and it was a time of lawlessness because
all the laws were suspended and people
the a bunch of singers who actually
wandered the streets naked singing and
then they had orgies sexual orgies it
was a mass so all this business about
mistletoe Pagan Christmas trees Pagan
giving out gifts Pagan every bit of it
is Pagan every single bit of his cable
we've christianized it all now did you
hear that if you want more details on
this go to our Channel and watch some of
the previous programs we've done over
the years going more into the details
about this holiday and its Origins some
people might say oh this is from a long
time ago just consider this small point
just consider this look at Kanye West
for example that's right you're not
Hitler you're not a Nazi you don't
deserve to be called that and demonized
well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also the Jew I love everyone I'm done
with the classifications every human
being has something of value that they
brought to the table especially Hitler
Kanye West got canceled for praising
this evil man who did many evil things
in history he was also a Christian by
the way by the name of Hitler you didn't
see any of Kanye's boys friends family
step up to get his back here did you
nobody came up to say oh this is freedom
of speech none of this they all
dissonance himself from him and they he
got canceled because it's clear in
people's mind what this man did and all
the evils that he did now for any person
who gets educated just because something
is packaged and all of the nice rappings
and gifts and family and whatnot people
when they end up looking into the orange
origins of this the same way someone
would go into the origins of this evil
man we just mentioned they want to
disses themselves from that this is why
we stay clear of such things Pagan every
bit of it is Pagan every single bit of
it and no muslim no human being should
want to come close to [ __ ] now I want to
share a if with you a verse from the
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah the
Quran where Allah is saying look this is
the creator of the heavens and earth
say if you really love Allah you're
claiming you do
other famous celebrities Muslims in
general you say I love Allah look Allah
is right here telling you how you can
truly love Allah so you can get that
love reciprocated because you want Allah
to love you here's the answer right here
say if you really love Allah then follow
me follow who the example of prophet
Muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
and then Allah will love you and forgive
you your sins for Allah is often
forgiving most merciful not just ponder
over that because I don't want to
primarily make this about this football
player Mo Salat is bigger is bigger than
him it's a struggle between polytheism
paganism and what we call verse the pure
monotheism and if a person dies on shirt
this is what God Almighty Allah tells us
they'll be in the Hellfire for eternity
so connecting it back to that Ayah the
verse from the greater word of God
Almighty we say we love Allah we say we
love Prophet Muhammad but look Prophet
Muhammad spent his whole life just like
Jesus did just like Moses did just like
Abraham did just like Noah all the
preceding messages that came before
Prophet Muhammad they spent their whole
life calling people to what to the pure
monotheism of worshiping the Creator and
not the creation and warning people
to stay far away from shirk associating
anything with God anything that comes
close to should they warn their people
of so here you come saying Mary shirk
that God Almighty had a son and a person
who reads the Quran and then the Ayah in
there talking about how the heavens and
the Earth for those who say that God
Almighty had a son how the heavens and
earth are ready to burst asunder because
of the statement that they made
[Music]
um
[Music]
brothers and sisters words are heavy and
we know from the Hadith that the prophet
Muhammad had warned us of this that a
person would utter one word not thinking
of the severity and for how deep how
deep into the Hellfire but a person will
say one good word not thinking about it
and then that person will get so much
reward so why take that chance another
thing that's very important brothers and
sisters is when the truth comes to us
via become to Mo Salah where it comes to
the hamzat where it comes to anybody to
me myself any of us if we're people
under Sunnah who love their creator
Allah who love the way of the Prophet
Muhammad sallam who loved the way of all
the prophets we have to be people when
the truth comes up we don't want to fall
into that category of people where the
Prophet Muhammad sallam he had said that
if a person has an Adam's weight of
pride
they will not end up in Jannah
can you imagine that paraphrase and
Hadith going further they said hey look
I'll message you of Allah we like to
dress nice look good I said no no it's
not about that
it is about when the truth comes to you
and you reject it you're too proud for
you too arrogant so year passes another
year passes another year passes people
are sending you the message and now
again you continue to wish the Mary
shook we have to check ourselves because
before we as the saying goes wreck
ourselves and we want to work to what
to please the Creator over pleasing the
creation
because as We Know
look there's so much wisdom when we
study our Deen all these things are
there giving us the answers
told us that look for the person who
works to please the creation over
pleasing the Creator Allah Allah will be
displeased with him or her and make the
creation also displeased with him let us
also remember these few points that our
main purpose in life is not to win the
hearts of the people it's to win
the attention of our creator to work to
please our creator before we meet our
creator
number two brothers and sisters do we
really know this tohi do we really
understand our Dean so we don't
compromise in it because at the end of
the day when you're in the grave it's
not going to be your fans in the great
you're going to be alone in that gray
brothers and sisters and you want to you
don't want to go in there saying Maddie
Sheikh or other things just not just let
your tongue be loose and saying whatever
you want just for the attention just for
the fame Just For the Glory at the end
of the day all that's going to be gone
you're going to have your deeds and
you're going to have to stand in front
of your creator with all of this you
don't want that life is too short
brothers and sisters and the last and
final part is when the truth comes are
we ready to admit our mistakes are we
ready to turn back and make it right
because Allah's love is Everlasting and
his Mercy is overflowing for us so let
us go ahead and do not despair because
Allah's Mercy is greater than anything
that we can imagine but we don't want to
be consistent in the Sin we'd only be
consistent displeasing Allah we want to
be humble and amid our mistakes and turn
back to the all loving the all-merciful
so let's end with that brothers and
sisters and take heed and we'll see you
next time until then assalamu alaikum
peace be with you we've been told that
they're out to kill us all
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters we
went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign